did you hear that was that your what
Stan I just I heard someone say hello
you know there's a lot of fish here
anybody literally anybody could have
just said alone yeah where am I looking
there oh hi yeah well we're your parents
was my family where did you see them
last I forgot I was looking for
something and I okay totally get it
date night I suffer from short-term
memory loss it runs in my family at
least I think it does where are they
Dorie there you are look out look this
our friend not take it into whatever
this place is it's a fish sauce pool
dude
name's Hank I have to find my family
that's a hard one kid my family not a
great swimmer our friend is in there
Walsh Stallone Bailey you've gotta use
it at the location mmm I feel stupid
poor babies let me get that for you she
should just pick two and let's go dad
what I'm kidding
I get the feeling they're fishing us for
a reason like something with one big eye
tentacles and snappy things well that's
very specific but something like that
somewhere out there is my family I can't
find him on my own I don't want to be
touched sorry
that's okay everybody does it nothing to
be ashamed of
I just think you trust BEC that he's
eating the top just keep swimming
does this mean you have to say goodbye
to Tori I don't know why I thought I
could do this
Dory you are about to find your parents
and when you do that you'll be sea lions
they are natural predators they could
pounce at any moment my don't you don't
you worry about one thing